An IDS can be deployed to
monitor a network or subnet.
It monitors traffic in real or
close to real time so
that it can react to
intrusions in a timely manner.
It can analyze traffic in multiple
layers of the network stack.
A network IDS can include
a number of sensors.
For example, each of them is
deployed to monitor a subnet.
In such case, it may include one or
more serves in the backend that manages
these censors and
interface with a human analyst.
Typically, a censor monitors
traffic of a subnet and
reports its finding to
the backend server.
Then, the backend management server
can correlate evidence across
multiple sensors to provide protection
or detection of the whole network.